but 12 years old sky brown set to be
Britain's youngest ever summer Olympian
she's grown up in LA and Japan and she's
now taking the world by storm the
skateboarding makes its debut at the
games everyone gets to see how close it
would hang is and how fun it is how
creative you can be with it
yeah I'm super excited I want to show
girls that it doesn't matter
about how old you are you can do
anything so if they see me the full girl
because I trick them they'll think that
I could do it so hopefully it's in her
back garden in Japan that Skye gets most
practice in along with her brother ocean
but she's also built up quite a
following along the boardwalks of LA I
don't really train like a skate parks
kind of like more my playgrounds like my
funds like happy place
I skate I surf I dance is there anything
that you're not good at yeah Carly like
getting ready for bed brushing my teeth
even after breaking her arm Skye got
straight back to competing she's now got
half a million followers on Instagram
who monitor her progress sometimes I
like skating with the boys kids makes me
want to push myself like go hard but I
do love skating with the girls and
that's why I like doing competitions
because I guess you're the girl skate
from all around the world
yeah and was really cool to see that
there's way more girls skating now I
feel like some people think that if you
do sports you can't be really a girly
girl
guys already achieved an awful lot but
she's now got our sights set on a podium
finish in Tokyo Rebecca wedding Sky News